but that fish boy
it's fish man
my son you could unite our worlds one
day the lamb
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not King I'm nobody you are part of
something deeper I can see that
[Music]
oh it's awesome thanks who's always had
a king you know I need something more
well what could be greater than a king
here
Aquaman this is gonna be fun
rated pg-13 see the new extended video
on YouTube now hey buddy you that fish
boy from the TV it's fish man you could
unite our worlds one day the land
[Music]
I'm not King the world needs something
more a hero
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Aquaman footage to break
down it's the world series so of course
they're dropping a whole bunch of new
trailers and there's a new round of that
giveaway for the DC streaming service
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave an Aquaman related
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this we start with
the bar fight and Amnesty Bay you're
that fish boy that's just them paying
back that moment where he's a little kid
in the aquarium and he has those bullies
then calls all the fish to him freaking
everybody out is then trying to show you
how he's grown since Justice League like
he would probably have thrown down on
the spot with people like that
and it's a bit of a callback also to the
Man of Steel
bar fight where Superman does not squish
those people that throw the beers at him
you may have noticed too there's a whole
bunch of scenes in the trailer that they
include with him yelling about how much
fun he's having after a huge explosions
or after getting the crap blown out of
him like this is so much fun they're
just the marketing department in James
Wan the director trying to remind you
about the tone of the film and it's sort
of a genre mashup is this big
swashbuckling adventure crossed with the
Nathan Drake Uncharted or Indiana Jones
because of all the treasure hunting and
all this big Game of Thrones level
mythology because of how Atlantis
originally sank and he has to unite the
seven different kingdoms of Atlantis
there's a whole new scene with his
mother at Lana speaking to him as a baby
this is his father holding him all
swallowed up so he's like really really
young here is probably when she has to
go back and take the throne of Atlantis
but the whole idea of him bringing peace
between the surface world in the world
of Atlantis is sort of like the
overarching plot but I think that most
people are gonna go into this movie more
focused on him taking the throne but
there's really like three different
stories going on in this you have him
taking the throne of Atlantis than him
uniting the seven different kingdoms of
Atlantis because all the different
rulers like King nearest who's Mira's
father played by Dolph Lundgren here he
has his own agenda so did the other
rulers of the other city-states
but then on a larger level within the DC
Universe he also has to bring peace
between the surface world in the world
of Atlantis there's another scene of
Mira using her hydro Kinesis powers
that's just one of the really cool
things she can do she's also crazy
strong like Wonder Woman
Aquaman above land physically she's not
quite as strong as Aquaman but she is
supposed to be close to Wonder Woman
levels but I think that they're trying
to make the Wonder Woman of the DC
movies a little more on par with
Superman but I believe Superman is still
supposed to be the most powerful person
on earth unless you're underwater and
then Aquaman could probably match him
toe-to-toe for at least a little while
this bridge blowing up seems like
Atlantean architecture but when Atlantis
was still above ground I'm assuming
because we get all these graham mctavish
flashbacks to King at land the first
high king of Atlantis we'll see how and
why Atlantis sank and broke into the
seven different nations there's a shot
of Aquaman in Chains underwater being
made to prostrate himself before someone
we see off screen this might be one of
the other rulers like Mira's father or
ocean master this is a brand-new shot of
black manta without a special suit
standing on top of his special ship all
of his gear and weaponry are Atlantean
designs given to him by ocean master
this way you see all these creatures in
the pressure suits running after them in
this big fast and furious chase scene we
finally get to see a picture of ocean
master in his full comic book armor this
is a picture of him in volcko riding
their primary underwater mounts the
costume looks great I was hoping they
would include it and after they did the
big Aquaman classic comic-book armor
reveal in the last big trailer I assumed
that they would do ocean master - like
if you're gonna do the Aquaman costume
you're probably gonna do everybody
else's comic book costumes - we get a
shot of Aquaman saying goodbye to his
father maybe this is after he decides to
make a go of it early in the film then
more of that seemed with them going all
Indiana Jones searching for a king at
Lance Trident amongst the ruins of
ancient Atlantis above-ground we finally
get to see Aquaman and black manta throw
down up close in the scene but it looks
like the beginning of the big chase
scene that they put in all the trailers
where he shows up blast the crap out of
them and they just start running through
all those buildings you get a bunch of
big wide shots of them flying through
Atlantis they have to do the same thing
for Atlantis in the DC Universe that the
Black Panther movie did for Wakanda in
the Marvel Universe like this is
supposed to be the most amazing city
that you've never seen before this is
why it's so special you get mirrors call
to action before he puts on the comic
book armor telling him he has to be this
mythic hero like King at land his
ancestor which is a big callback to that
Justice League Flash
scene with Steppenwolf where all the
people of the earth were united you have
King at land the Atlanteans fighting
with the Amazons the gods in the humans
to get rid of Steppenwolf this sort of
the dream of the DC Universe where you
have the Justice League people
representing different parts of the
planet bringing everyone together to
fight as one but the really cool thing
that we learned from behind the scenes
is that when Justice League was still
originally going to be broken into two
films this flashback scene was
originally supposed to be them fighting
a very young version of Darkseid they
bite him up he leaves the mother boxes
and then for the most part the plot
proceeds in the same way where
Steppenwolf leads to a scene with dark
side and Darkseid becomes the big
villain to that second film so right now
if you're still really hyped up for
seeing Darkseid at some point in the DC
movie universe it seems like the first
big movie they're planning on putting
him in is gonna be the New Gods movie
but we don't have a release date for
that yet and we don't know what the tone
is gonna be or which comic books it's
gonna be inspired by but presumably it's
gonna include all the really big Jack
Kirby fourth-world characters so I am
really excited to see what its gonna
look like but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
all this so far obviously Aquaman isn't
coming out to the Christmas holiday
season so we'll probably get a couple
more trailers before it gets here for
those of you asking about the timeline
this movie picks up in present day after
the events of Justice League so he's
already been through all that stuff with
the rest of them and they did explain
that it's meant to be relatively
self-contained
so I'm not expecting any really big
cameos from the other Justice League
members maybe they'll be a post-credits
scene with Wonder Woman or Shazam
that'll help set up their movies Shazam
is the next movie that's coming out
though Flynn fact the Shazam movie meant
to introduce magic on a different level
within the DC Universe magic is also a
big part of Atlantean Society for
instance the shield that protects
Atlantis and hides it from view the same
way that there's a shield over a thermos
Kiera is magical in nature so there is a
lot of magic in Atlantean society they
get into that in the more recent rebirth
DC Comics but I don't know how they're
gonna try and weave that into the
Aquaman movie nothing that I've seen
from any of the trailers gives any kind
of hint that magic exists within this
society think of them like a really
ancient culture that just has evolved so
much that magic isn't so much magic to
them it's just science that most people
haven't figured out yet
Marvel kind of did that in the Doctor
Strange movie where they tried to
provide a scientific explanation for how
they weave their spells and where they
pull that energy from in other
dimensions there was some cool Marvel
news about a Hawkeye project that's
happening during Marvel phase four so I
might do a video for that next later
tonight but leave all your video
requests in the comments below Marvel DC
anything else congratulations arrow 22
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big DC video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
longer extended Aquaman footage and
click here for that brand new Captain
Marvel video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]